hey  i have a few years of google workspace  administration experience and i'm  looking for options to show my skills to  the world  have you considered the google cloud  professional collaboration engineer  certification it's basically a  professional stamp of approval  this exam will assess your ability to  plan and implement the google workspace  authorization and access manage user  resource and shared drive life cycles  manage mail and much more check out the  exam guide  what is the test like it's a two hour  multiple choice exam that you can take  in a dedicated testing center or in a  remote location via online proctoring  this is great thanks any advice on where  to start there are tons of training  resources sample questions and on-demand  courses check it out